Prof: Last week we ended
with the Boston Massacre in
1770,
and I mentioned at the very end
of the lecture the ways in which
both onlookers in the British
government and the colonists
ended up wondering,
each one, if the other one was
somehow engaged in a plot.
Right?
And I mentioned that the
British were perhaps wondering
if this had all been a plot to
rob the customs house;
the colonists were wondering
about the possibility of this
being some kind of ongoing plot
to subdue and repress the
American colonists.
So clearly at the end of the
lecture from last week you can
really begin to sense a growing
sense of mounting hostility,
even among some people a sense
of growing alienation.
And you can hear this on both
sides coming from the accounts
of the Boston Massacre by both
Gage and Adams--and I read from
them last week.
And I did mention in class when
I read from them that they were
of course writing with a purpose
in mind so they were interested
in being particularly bold and
dramatic in what they were
saying.
Gage really had to excuse what
happened and Adams was trying to
promote people to get upset
about what had happened,
but even so you can hear even
just in the way that they framed
their accounts some of what I'm
talking about here with growing
hostility,
growing alienation.
So for example,
Gage at the very start of the
letter that I read from in the
last lecture tells the person
he's writing to that he's
writing this letter to inform
the King's ministry,
quote, "of the critical
situation of the troops and the
hatred of the people towards
them."
That's how he starts his
letter, which is really
interesting.
So to Gage, clearly,
what he's stating in this
letter to his people back home
within the King's Ministry is
that it doesn't really even feel
safe for British soldiers on the
streets of Boston;
the people here hate us.
And Adams also emphasizes this
kind of growing alienation and
animosity,
and in his case he does it in a
particularly strong way in a
series of newspaper articles for
the Boston Gazette that
he wrote a few months after the
massacre.
So Adams writes:
"I appeal to the common
sense of mankind.
To what a state of misery and
infamy must a people be reduced!
To have a governor by the sole
appointment of the crown;
under the absolute control of a
weak and arbitrary minister,
to whose dictates he is to
yield an unlimited obedience,
or forfeit his political
career: while he is to be
supported at the expense of the
people,
by virtue of an authority
claimed by
strangers."
And that's really an
interesting statement.
Strangers--He's referring to
Parliament.
Right?
It's these strangers who are
telling these officials what to
do.
That's again a striking word
and a striking statement.
Now of course,
here Adams says that really
striking thing--
and then he's careful to add
right after it that,
quote, "For opposing a
threatened tyranny we have been
not only called,
but in effect adjudged rebels
and traitors to the best of
kings."
OK--He's making a really
important distinction there.
He's saying,
'Yes, maybe we're upset at what
Parliament is doing,
maybe Parliament is behaving
like a group of strangers,
but we are still good British
subjects and we are loyal to our
King,
to the best of kings.'
And it's an important point,
that even in the midst of all
of this animosity and all of
these misunderstandings,
troops are in Boston streets
and the colonists obviously
still feel like British subjects
who are loyal to their King and
who are objecting because their
rights as British subjects are
being violated.
That's the logic that we're
working on here.
And you can see this in
Adams--Samuel Adams' actions.
At the same time that he's
writing all these sort of
propaganda newspaper accounts
and trying to stir up animosity,
he also was writing letters to
people in England trying to
persuade them and hopefully
inspire them to persuade others
that the people of Boston were
rightfully defending their
liberties and deserved to be
defended by people in
Parliament,
not condemned and punished.
Equally important,
the colonists were not saying
that they wanted nothing to do
with Parliament,
or even that Parliament had no
authority over the colonies--
even though the occasional bold
statement sort of runs out on an
edge and says 'we hate
Parliament.'
Most colonists thought that the
colonists--the colonies were
subordinate to Parliament in
some way.
The problem,
Massachusetts Governor Thomas
Hutchinson later remarked,
is that subordination,
quote, "was a word without
any precise meaning to it."
Okay?
That's a really insightful
comment.
Yeah, okay, colonies are
subordinate but what does that
mean?
And obviously what we're
looking at now is a sort of
non-debate debate in which it's
clear people have different
understandings of exactly what
the imperial system is supposed
to look like and how it
functions.
So all in all it's important to
remember here that even with all
of this friction that we're
seeing between colonists and the
British,
the colonists are still loyal
British subjects who want the
imperial system to function
happily again.
And this is a really great
example of why it's always
important--
and I think it's particularly
important when studying anything
in the founding era,
but I think history
generally--but when studying the
Revolution or the founding era--
but when studying the
Revolution, it's important not
to jump on to the independence
bandwagon too quickly and assume
that a separation is inevitable,
because the people that we're
studying did not assume that.
It's so easy for us to assume
that, right?
Because we know it's
coming--but remember Freeman's
Top Tips for Studying the
Revolution, right?
Contingency.
Our historical subjects didn't
know what was going to
happen--and anything could have
happened.
So from our perspective,
we're looking at the events
here-- we almost can't help it,
I think on all of our parts,
even on my part.
It all looks like a ticking
clock,
like there's an inevitable
pulling away from the British,
and everything I talk about
here represents one step closer
to independence,
another step closer to
independence.
And part of what I'm trying to
say here is: clearly that's not
how the colonists or the British
at this point are thinking.
That's not how they understand
their actions.
what's happening.
The colonists at this point are
not trying to rebel and they're
not trying to retreat away from
the British empire.
They're trying to fix things.
They're trying to figure out
how to fix things.
So in a sense,
the best way to understand the
events of the first half of the
1770s is to look at the whole
revolutionary era without
thinking about the Revolution,
and by that I mean the war.
Just forget that there's going
to be a war.
The war doesn't exist.
I--Always as a historian I do
this to myself when I'm sitting
down to write something,
like if I'm writing a
project--as I'm working on a
book now that takes me up to the
Civil War,
so I have to constantly say,
'Civil War?
I don't know if they had a
Civil War.
What Civil War?'
Because my subjects aren't
assuming until a very late point
that there might be one.
And I'm sort of saying the same
thing here,
that it's useful to just sort
of put the assumption that
there's going to be a war over
here and watch the logic of
events as they unfold.
It's a good reminder I think
for the study of history
generally,
because part of what you're
trying to do as historians is
understand what your historical
subjects are thinking and why
they're thinking that way,
and you make that much harder
when you stick the outcome right
in front of them and compare
what they're doing with what you
assume to be an inevitable
outcome.
Okay.
Now I mentioned last time that
one way in which the colonists
responded to the Townshend Acts
was to propose boycotting
British goods again,
as they had before--in their
minds successfully--
with the Stamp Act.
So now, feeling even more
threatened, the colonists didn't
simply urge a boycott in an
informal way.
Now they actually organize.
So remember there's a pattern I
pointed out in an earlier
lecture when I was talking about
previous attempts at colonial
union,
and I mentioned in that lecture
that one of the main things that
really drives the colonies to
join together in an effort is
some kind of a threat--
so basically self-defense is a
really good motivator.
And so typically in the past
something would threaten the
colonies,
inter-colonial unity suddenly
seemed important,
there'd be some kind of a
movement to do something
together for the moment,
and then when the crisis passed
the unity passed as well.
So we're sort of seeing some of
that go into operation here.
Way down the road for
Americans, one of the big
lessons of the Revolution would
ultimately be how powerful it is
when you combine and organize
and associate--
when you form associations or
organizations--
and as we'll begin to see soon,
when people organize into small
coordinated groups,
they can have an enormous
impact--and that's essentially
what happens here in the course
of the American Revolution.
So between 1768 and 1770,
as they begin to contemplate
boycotting British goods yet
again, people begin to form
non-importation associations,
okay?
Non-importation associations.
Now these associations--these
organizations in a sense--
were extra-constitutional,
so they're springing up from
outside of the formal political
system,
but in a variety of different
ways they actually had some real
power.
In the North,
merchants were at the core of
this movement,
this non-importation
association movement,
although it was grounded on
popular support,
but merchants were really at
the center of it because one key
to the success of this whole
endeavor was for merchants to
join together in promising not
to import British goods.
And sometimes merchants
actually signed written
agreements that they would not
import British goods,
so unity among the merchants
could be a powerful thing and in
the North that operated pretty
effectively.
So for example,
when--And I swear I'm really
not inserting Rhode Island into
every moment in which a random
bad thing happens.
Today we have two--at least
two--several Rhode Island
moments,
and every time I come across
one I think,
is it just because I'm aware of
Rhode Island?
Is it because I'm thinking
about Rhode Island that Rhode
Island appears to be there so
much?
But it makes me think of--I got
my undergraduate degree at
Pomona College in California,
and Pomona has a thing about
the number forty-seven,
which they think appears
everywhere, right?
Everything is forty-seven,
so when you go to Pomona,
it's like the magic of
forty-seven constantly being
talked about.
You add letters up to various
things,
and it always equals --
ooh!--forty-seven,
and then people graduate from
Pomona and go on to become film
writers and then you'll see all
these forty-sevens.
Everyone's like:
there's another one in Star
Wars;
it's a forty-seven!
So forty-seven was the Pomona
thing and after a while you
begin to think well,
if I'm looking for forty-sevens
I'm always going to find
forty-sevens.
So today I actually--when I was
writing this,
I thought, maybe I'm doing that
to Rhode Island.
I hope not, but here is a Rhode
Island moment,
okay?
And it's an actual Rhode Island
moment.
Some Rhode Island merchants
threatened to pull out of the
non-importation agreement
because it's proving to be
troublesome in a variety of
ways,
so when these Rhode Island
merchants threatened this,
merchants in Boston and New
York and Philadelphia actually
imposed a boycott on Newport and
Providence, Rhode Island.
Right?
Okay.
There's the power of
association.
'Oh, you're going to--think
you're going to import British
goods?
Okay.
We boycott you,
Rhode Island.'
[laughs]
'You're now going to be
boycotted.'
That's pretty powerful.
So merchants were key here,
as was the public.
So for example,
in various places in the North,
colonial legislatures sometimes
passed resolutions commending
these non-importation
associations to the people.
Right? The people are vital too.
So you have colonial
legislatures passing resolutions
to the public saying,
this whole association effort
here is good and you should
really listen to it,
basically lending legitimacy to
what were essentially really ad
hoc organizations,
ad hoc committees.
Now in the South,
the non-importation
associations were more centered
on the populace,
not quite as centered on
merchants,
so southern non-importation
associations were often very
careful to have members sign on
from throughout the community,
so not just merchants but
artisans and planters.
And because in the South they
were more popularly based,
they were more centered on
non-consumption than on
non-importation--
but of course if you're looking
at the North,
it's all about seaports and
importing goods.
It makes sense that in the
South, maybe there'd be more of
a focus on not consuming
imported British goods,
as opposed to not importing
British goods.
Now as suggested in the
comments that I just made about
northern legislatures supporting
northern non-importation
associations,
it's important to note that
these are not rebellious groups
acting against the structure of
colonial government.
They're not competing with
colonial assemblies.
They're actually in some ways
acting in harmony with them,
and as a matter of fact some
people who were in these
non-importation associations
probably were in the colonial
legislatures too.
So we're not talking about
opposing efforts.
We're talking about sort of
parallel efforts that sometimes
intersect.
Okay.
So as organizations linking the
will of the people with
politicized action,
these associations are pretty
significant because--
I'm sure you can see now just
based on my description of
them--
they're really promoting broad,
popular,
organized, coordinated
politicized action.
And this model is going to
become more and more significant
as the Revolution continues on.
And broadly based as they were,
these associations really did
help to spread a sense of
popular involvement in
resistance to British policy.
Boycotting British goods was a
political act and everyone from
all levels of society including
women could be involved in this
in some way,
spreading a real sense of
popular involvement in acts of
resistance to these seemingly
unfair acts of Parliament.
So average people--we're not
just talking legislators and
political radicals like Samuel
Adams--
but average people had a sense
of involvement in a larger
cause.
And newspaper articles and
broadsides helped spread this
sense of involvement,
urging the colonists to avoid
luxuries like imported silks or
English rum,
and instead people should be
virtuous and they should wear
homespun clothing made of cloth
that could be made in the
colonies,
and they should drink whiskey
and beer and cider that could be
made in the colonies.
Now you'll notice things to
drink include whiskey,
beer and cider,
but you'll notice water
[laughter]
isn't included in that list--
and actually it wasn't
considered a normal beverage at
this point in time,
which I always thought was an
interesting fact.
And when I was in grad school I
read this really interesting
British novel written in 1796.
It has a very strange title.
The title is Hermsprong;
Or Man As He is Not.
There were a lot of novels
at the time called Man as He
is,
Man as He is Not--but what
Hermsprong is about,
among other things,
is: the central character is
this American in England,
and he's this sort of exotic,
strange,
independent-minded creature.
And two things that he does
that are sort of shockingly
bizarre to all of the British
onlookers in this novel is:
he walks places instead of
riding in a carriage.
'Oh, my gosh.
He got up this morning from the
tavern and went walking.'
And then the second even more
horrifying thing is:
he drinks water.
[laughter] He drank water.
He had a normal dinner.
He drank water.
And there's a weird scene in it
in which someone says,
'I can't even describe to you
what water tastes like.
Why do you drink it?
Water has no taste.'
'Water tastes like,' Hermsprong
says, 'water.'
[laughs]
Water tastes like water.
That was kind of radical.
So, being very patriotic here,
drink whiskey,
beer and cider,
period.
[laughs]
Don't worry about that boring
water stuff.
It's fascinating that that's
considered a weird thing at that
time.
Okay.
So people are encouraged to
drink and wear only
colonial-made goods,
and this was true all over the
place.
So as a symbolic gesture,
Harvard students gave up
drinking tea.
Students at the College of New
Jersey, now Princeton,
wore homespun clothing.
And students at Yale
[laughs]--I wonder what this
says about Yale--renounced
imported wines.
[laughter] Huh?
[laughs]
I actually went and
double-checked that.
I was like: really?
[laughter] Yeah, really.
[laughs] Yale. Okay.
South Carolina assemblymen
renounced the wearing of wigs
and stockings--
which must have looked very
odd--with the result one
observer noted,
that a foreign visitor arriving
in Charleston,
quote, "would probably
from their dress take them for
so many unhappy persons ready
for execution who had come to
petition for a pardon."
[laughter]
Some of these people with no
wigs and no--kind of dressed
really badly and hanging out in
the legislature.
Okay.
So clearly, based on those
examples, even Yale students,
non-import--although maybe I
don't know about the--[laughs]
not having imported wine.
Non-importation does represent
one way in which many people,
and as I said before including
women,
became directly involved in
colonial protest efforts.
But women were often the
primary purchasers of goods,
so their actions were central
on this front.
They had to be appealed to,
they had to be included,
so non-importation politicized
the daily activities of women as
well as men,
spreading feelings of
community-level patriotism with
people joined in a joint
political effort to defend their
rights.
So you have people who are sort
of joined in this effort of
patriotic austerity;
they're all sort of joining in
a willingness to sacrifice
luxuries for a worthy cause.
Now of course not every
American and not every colonist
is doing this,
so when I say "joined,
everyone's joined,"
maybe not everyone,
but there were a lot of people
who were paying attention to
this idea of non-importation.
But of course,
now that I've made
non-importation sound so
impressive,
I will add that it ultimately
was not a roaring success
because,
as I just hinted a minute ago,
not everyone really found it
very easy to surrender English
luxuries,
and as always there was a lot
of smuggling.
So it wasn't an amazing roaring
success but that said,
there was some impact on
British manufacturers and there
was some recognition that
considering the relatively small
amount of revenue being raised
by the Townshend Acts,
maybe the effort wasn't worth
all of the trouble.
So some onlookers in Britain
began to regret the Townshend
Acts.
And it's important to note even
Members of Parliament who were
sympathetic to the colonies and
who wanted the Townshend Acts
repealed--
even these sympathetic Members
didn't question the right of
Parliament to tax the colonies.
They may have felt that
Parliament was behaving too
aggressively or unwisely,
maybe it's an unwise policy,
but even people who were--
considered themselves sort of
supporters,
real dire supporters of the
American colonists,
even they were not questioning
the constitutional supremacy of
Parliament to tax the British
colonies.
That's almost like a line in
the sand.
So along these lines,
despite the fact that you have
some people in Parliament who
are sympathetic towards the
colonies,
Parliament could not just back
down and take all of the
Townshend Acts back,
and there are two main reasons
for that.
There's such power when you say
that: 'there are two
reasons'--and a hundred people
go "gonk."
Satisfaction.
Note-taking.
But there are two main reasons.
First and most obvious,
Parliament just didn't want to
lose face.
Right?
They felt that they truly were
upholding the supremacy and
sovereignty of the British
Parliament.
Second, related to that and
perhaps more important as far as
our understanding of different--
two evolving mindsets is
concerned,
the sovereignty of Parliament
over the colonies by this point
had become inextricably bound up
with the right of taxing
Americans.
And I'll repeat that again.
By this point,
the sovereignty of Parliament
over the colonies had become
inextricably bound up with the
right of taxing American
colonists.
So at this point,
Parliament couldn't back down
on a tax without seeming to give
up their sovereignty over the
colonies.
By 1770, the right of taxation
was not just a means of
producing revenue for the
British,
but it actually had become an
assertion of British sovereignty
over its own colonies.
Okay.
So now we're in 1770 and
surprise, surprise,
by this time we have a new
Prime Minister.
Lord North is now Prime
Minister.
Townshend is gone,
although we're sort of in a
period of revolving doors of
Prime Ministers,
but in this case Townshend
died.
Townshend actually died back in
1767 and so Lord North is the
next person who comes along.
Townshend's Acts live on
without him for a little while,
but now Lord North is the Prime
Minister so he assumes this
position and with familiar logic
he decides that the only way to
withdraw the Townshend Acts is
going to be to leave behind a
token tax in the colonies to
prove that England reigned
supreme over its colonial
properties.
As Lord North himself put it,
"If I thought I could
appease that factious and
disobedient temper which
prevails, I should be glad to do
it.
And yet, to these people,
who ought to be our subjects,
we are to make concessions,
because they have the hardihood
to set us at defiance!...
Upon my word,
if we are to run after America
in search of reconciliation,
in this way,
I do not know a single act of
Parliament that will
remain."
But despite having said all
that, North concluded this
speech by saying he wanted to
be,
quote, "thought,
what I really am,
to the best of my conviction--a
friend to trade,
a friend to America."
Okay.
There's a lot of stuff bound up
in that statement--
but you can really see him
processing through what's
happening versus what he assumes
about the workings of the
imperial system.
It's a complicated situation to
North and the British as well as
to the colonies.
So in the end,
thinking about all of this and
thinking well,
I need to leave some kind of
tax in place to prove
Parliamentary supremacy,
he decides to leave the tea tax
in effect,
and the logic behind that is,
of all the taxed items this was
the most profitable to England,
and it couldn't be manufactured
in the colonies,
so it would have to be
imported--plus it was kind of
central to socializing.
Everybody drank tea.
That was the thing to do--was
to drink tea with great
ceremony--
among some people to have tea
cups and tea spoons--
so North just assumed on a
whole bunch of levels:
can't be easily boycotted;
they really like tea in those
colonies, just like us here;
makes us a reasonable amount of
money;
that's the thing that'll stay.
Now when I was writing this
lecture, I was thinking about
that.
I was thinking about tea and
tea ceremonies and the drinking
of tea,
and I suppose we all have in
our mind a sense of that being
the case in England,
but it was no less the case in
the colonies.
And when I was--I guess when I
was researching my first book I
came across a story.
I'm going to mention it now
only because it relates to the
tea ceremony and this is my
opportunity to tell this story.
There will be random moments
when I just have to tell a story
'cause you guys are like
hostages.
[laughter]
It means I get to say whatever
I want and I get to tell random
stories--
but this actually does
demonstrate the sort of ritual
of tea drinking everywhere.
So the whole tea ceremony was
important in the colonies.
I came across this account from
a foreign observer,
actually from France.
And he shows up in the
colonies, and he says in a
letter to a friend that he'd
never quite seen anything like
the colonial obsession with
serving tea.
And he describes this visit
that he paid to a woman,
and he said that he would take
a sip and then she would
immediately refill the cup,
so he couldn't figure out how
to empty the cup.
Basically, he doesn't want any
more tea [laughs]
and he can't figure out how to
make it stop coming.
'I'll drink a little more fast.
Maybe she'll'--And he kept
basically trying out one thing
after another and she kept
refilling the cup--
and then he felt compelled to
drink,
because it was the proper thing
to do--
was to eat or drink what he was
served.
He didn't know that the code in
the tea ceremony to stop tea
from being poured was to place
your tea spoon across the top of
your cup.
Right?
He didn't think about that,
so at one point he's desperate,
because he just can't deal with
any more tea.
So she pours more tea in his
cup and when she turned away he
actually swallowed everything in
the cup in a gulp and then put
the cup in his pocket.
[laughter]
Like she's not going to notice.
[laughs]
Right?
Oh, you ate the cup.
[laughter]
And he doesn't say what
happened.
He just describes putting it in
his pocket like:
There.
Now I've settled that.
Great thinking.
[laughter]
They were serious about tea
ceremonies.
Okay.
So with full knowledge of the
cultural importance of tea in
the colonies,
North left the tea tax in
effect, hoping that a slight
concession on the part of
England maybe would chip away at
colonial unity.
Right?
Maybe some colonists would be
convinced to stop resisting,
maybe non-importation would
thus collapse--and eventually
non-importation does collapse.
It kind of dribbles to a
close--1770,1771.
And as with the Stamp Act,
both the colonies and the
British administration assumed
that they had emerged from this
victorious.
Right?
The colonies think ha,
we got most of those offensive
acts repealed.
Parliament thinks well,
we are still maintaining our
sovereignty so our point stands
firm.
And of course this did nothing
to resolve the conflict about
the precise nature of
sovereignty,
the precise nature of the
imperial system,
and the precise power of
Parliament over the colonies.
At about this time,
however, Lord North once again,
thinking about the colonies,
attempting reform,
he's struggling clearly--You
have to feel--
I just feel bad for a Prime
Minister at this moment of
massive confusion in the
colonies.
He's trying to figure out some
way to get colonial affairs in
control,
so at this point he figures
maybe one way to sort of calm
things down is to focus on
Massachusetts.
Right?
Massachusetts is the pesky
colony, bad things happen in
Massachusetts,
so he says maybe one way to
resolve things is to make a few
little tweaks in their political
system.
So he decides that henceforth
Superior Court judges will be
paid by tax revenue collected by
the Crown from the colonies,
which means in effect Superior
Court judges are not going to be
paid by colonial legislatures;
they're going to be paid by the
Crown.
Okay.
So certainly to some people in
Massachusetts this seemed like
it's a way to make judges
accountable to British
authorities and not to
colonists,
and in a sense that was part of
what North was trying to do
here.
But unfortunately about the
same time, in June of 1772,
there was a crisis in Rhode
Island.
[laughter]
A British ship,
the Gaspee,
which was used in Rhode Island
to prevent smuggling,
ran aground in Rhode Island and
that night colonists swarmed
aboard it,
forced the crew off and burned
it to the ground.
That's kind of a strong
anti-British "we hate that
you're stopping smuggling"
act.
So the Crown responded by
creating a commission of inquiry
to investigate the matter,
and ultimately this committee
decides it's going to let this
slide,
which is a major concession
because [laughs]
burning one of His Majesty's
ships is a serious matter.
Right? It's not a minor crime.
Even so, colonists just took
offense at the existence of the
commission which seemed to
interfere with the internal
affairs of a colony,
and even worse--this gets back
to something that people have
been upset about in the colonies
before--
the commission would have sent
the people who were going to be
tried to England for their
trials,
right?
So--and this also feels like a
threat to self-rule.
So you have these sorts of
things going on.
They're individual acts.
They're not connected,
but they're--in the eyes of
many colonists not good things.
Samuel Adams,
brilliant propagandist that he
is,
decides there has to be an
immediate response to these new
encroachments on colonial rights
and it needs to not just be in
Boston.
There needs to be a widespread
inter-state protest to what's
happening and to the
implications of what's
happening.
So in November of 1772,
building on the whole model of
the non-importation
associations,
he suggests in the Boston town
meeting that a committee of
correspondence be formed in
Boston to communicate the
current state of affairs in
Boston to the rest of the colony
and,
quote, "to the
world"-- right?
He's ambitious,
Samuel Adams--and to solicit
responses.
So a committee of
correspondence of roughly
twenty-one men is created with
the purpose--
as stated in the Boston town
meeting--
of stating, quote,
"the rights of the
Colonists and of this Province
in particular,
as men and Christians,
and as subjects"--
which is an interesting
trio--as men,
as Christians and as subjects,
and "to communicate and
publish the same to the several
towns and to the world as the
sense of this town,
with the infringements and
violations thereof that have
been,
or from time to time may be,
made." Right?
Infringements that have been
made or may be made,
right?
So he's even--Something else is
going to happen,
and if it is,
we've got a committee of
correspondence in place.
So by the end of November of
1772,
the committee had produced an
open letter to all of the towns
in Massachusetts urging them,
quote, not "to doze or sit
supinely indifferent on the
brink of destruction"--
that Samuel Adams;
he's really a master at the
strong words--and to create
their own committees of
correspondence.
And more than half of the towns
in Massachusetts responded,
encouraging more widespread
participation in the controversy
than before,
more widespread willingness to
act alongside the normal
political system to protest what
people saw as an
unconstitutional act--
and there were more than eighty
of these local committees of
correspondence created within
just a few months.
One observer called these
committees,
quote, "the foulest,
subtlest and most venomous
serpent ever issued from the egg
of sedition."
And you can kind of see this
person's fears.
Right?
This is a person who sees what
he perceives to be as organized
resistance to the British
government sort of bubbling up
in Massachusetts.
And this sort of bubbling
committees,
these committees of
correspondence are going to be
spreading sedition,
according to this person,
throughout the colonies and
possibly to the world.
And this person had a right to
be suspicious,
because organized resistance is
partly what these committees are
all about.
So this unfolding of events in
Massachusetts led radicals
elsewhere to do what
Massachusetts had done,
and create their own committees
of correspondence for
communication within colonies
and between the colonies.
So within roughly a year,
by very, very early in 1774,
there were committees of
correspondence in almost every
colony.
And these committees did a
number of things.
They strengthened ties between
radical colonies like
Massachusetts and less active or
less-radical colonies,
and they created a way for
radical-minded people in
different colonies to interact
with each other.
So clearly these committees of
correspondence--
just like the non-importation
associations--
are an important stepping-stone
in the growing sense of colonial
unity.
Now it was at this moment that
Lord North passed the Tea Act.
It actually had less to do with
the colonies than it had to do
with a miserably timed
necessity.
North was trying to save the
East India Tea Company from
collapse.
The Tea Act of 1773 removed
import duties on East India tea,
which basically made British
tea cheaper than Dutch tea,
in the hope that this would
inspire colonists to purchase
British tea.
Okay.
So you would think and
certainly you can understand why
Lord North would think that this
would make the colonists happy
because he is lowering duties on
tea.
The East India Company
hopefully, as he's thinking,
would be solvent,
maybe the Townshend Act,
my little tea tax left in place
there,
is going to matter less because
I've just lowered duties on some
tea,
so maybe now the colonists will
pay the tea tax,
Parliament will obviously have
the right to tax the colonies in
their eyes,
and maybe this will actually
quiet things a little.
But once again the British
government misjudged the
colonial reaction--
again showing how you have
different evolving mindsets here
and they're not necessarily,
either one, understanding
what's happening in the other
case.
So the colonists not
surprisingly had their own
interpretation of the act.
They actually felt that the act
was granting a monopoly to the
East India Tea Company,
enforcing the control of the
British government over what
they felt like was supposed to
be free trade,
so maybe in the future the
British would begin to control
the importation of other goods
as well.
Okay, so somewhat paradoxically
by reducing the duty on English
tea,
North helped fuel colonial
fears that there was a plot in
England against colonial
rights--
which inspired the colonists to
imagine the worst immediately
when a suspicious act was
passed.
So: 'oh, this must be part of
that plot, this Tea Act.
Yes, he may seem to be lowering
the duty on tea.
There must be another motive.
Ah, they must be trying to
control our trade.'
You can sort of see on both
sides how the logic makes sense.
You can also see how this is a
problem.
As with the Stamp Act,
colonists responded by
pinpointing the people who would
be distributing the tea,
right?
So first, you didn't want to be
a stamp agent;
now you don't want to be a
person selling tea.
So they pinpointed the
merchants who were selling tea
and they pressured them not to
sell it.
And broadsides were posted in
public places to inform and
involve the populace,
saying things like:
"Friends!--
Brethren!-- Countrymen--that
worst of plagues,
the detested TEA,
shipped for this port by the
East-India Company,
is now arrived in this Harbour;
the Hour of Destruction,
or manly opposition to the
Machinations of Tyranny,
stares you in the face."
It's a big drama.
These are not people who do
things halfway:
destruction--staring you in the
face--tyranny--manly opposition.
So when ships loaded with tea
began arriving in major colonial
ports, obviously things become
more heated.
In some cities the tea was just
unloaded and then locked up in a
warehouse and left there,
not sold.
In Philadelphia and New York
they actually kept these ships
with tea on them out away from
the harbor,
so that they just never came in
close to shore.
However, in Boston [laughs]
Governor Hutchinson decided to
force the issue,
in his mind as a means of
protecting British sovereignty
in the colonies.
So Hutchinson ordered the tea
ships to be unloaded.
Okay.
So we have an eyewitness
account of someone who heard the
response to that announcement,
who heard what happened when
it--people heard that Hutchinson
was going to ask for the tea to
be unloaded and it was at a
Boston town meeting:
December 16,1773.
Basically, people knew that
there was this tea-bearing ship
in the harbor,
and they knew that on December
16, in the evening,
the captain of that ship was
going to go to the town meeting
and tell the town meeting--
Samuel Adams who was chairing
the meeting--
what was going to happen with
the tea.
People knew that,
and thus there was an enormous
crowd gathered outside of the
Old South Church where the
meeting was being held to see
what would happen.
Right?
So everyone knows this is the
stare-down.
Okay. What's going to happen?
Is the tea coming off the boats?
And if the tea's coming off the
boats, what happens next?
Big crowd, and here's what this
eyewitness heard as the crowd
learned that Hutchinson was
insisting on the unloading of
the tea.
So this eyewitness,
he's at home drinking tea
[laughs]
when he said,
I heard "such prodigious
shouts...
that induced me,
while drinking tea at home,
to go out and know the cause of
it.
The meeting house was so
crowded I could get no farther
than the porch ...You'd have
thought that the inhabitants of
the infernal regions had broke
loose.
For my part,
I went contentedly home and
finished my tea."
[laughter] What's going on?
I got to go finish my tea.
[laughs]
"But was soon informed
what was going forward."
Right?
Is soon told they're going to
unload the tea,
"but still not crediting
it without ocular
demonstration"
[laughs]
okay,
eighteenth century:
I wanted to see it for myself,
right?
But not crediting it without
"ocular
demonstration,"
I went to watch.
Okay.
So our eyewitness goes off to
get ocular demonstrations of the
unloading of the tea,
but what he ends up watching is
an assemblage of somewhere
between thirty and sixty men
disguised as Indians aboard
three ships on Griffin's Wharf,
and these men basically worked
on those ships for several hours
and threw 342 chests of tea over
the side.
A huge number of people watched
from the docks and,
as I mentioned before when I
was talking about the Stamp Act,
riots and popular
demonstrations were kind of a
regular part of the system in
the colonies.
Riots were not normally chaotic
moments of violence and disorder
unless you were
shingle-by-shingle taking apart
[laughs]
the house of the stamp agent
for example,
but usually they were almost
ritualized demonstrations of
protest.
So what we have here is not a
wild riot on these ships.
Protestors were so careful not
to do anything other than make
their point,
not to do anything other than
destroy tea,
that allegedly they brought a
locksmith with them to open
locks or repair locks that were
broken.
These are people who understand
property rights.
Right?
'We value property.
We don't want to break your
locks.'
They're not actually out to get
the ship owners;
they just want the tea.
So they actually were very
orderly about the way in which
they went to destroy the tea.
So to give us a sense of what
happened, I'm going to use an
account by another man.
His name is George Hughes.
He actually helped destroy the
tea, so he's one of the people
throwing chests of tea over the
side.
And in his account,
Hughes says that back at the
Old South Church,
the announcement that
Hutchinson was going to order
the unloading of the tea led to,
quote, "a general huzzah
for Griffin's Wharf."
A huzzah is an
eighteenth-century hooray:
'hooray, off to Griffin's
Wharf.'
So these guys were like:
You're going to unload the tea?
We're there [laughs]
and something bad is going to
happen.
So Hughes, a participant in
what would come to be known--
but not until well into the
nineteenth century--
as the Boston Tea Party,
continues his account.
He says, "It was now
evening, and I immediately
dressed myself in the costume of
an Indian equipped with a small
hatchet...
with which and a club,
after having painted my face
and hands with coal dust in the
shop of a blacksmith,
I repaired to Griffin's Wharf
where the ships lay that
contained the tea,"
and Hughes is ordered to go to
the captain and "demand of
him the keys to the
hatches"
because they don't want to
damage the ship,
"and a dozen candles"
so that they can see what
they're doing.
[laughs]
Right?
Just being very sort of polite
here.
"The captain promptly
replied and delivered the
articles but requested me at the
same time to do no damage to the
ship or rigging."
So these Indians cut and split
the tea chests with their
tomahawks and threw them
overboard.
There were some people who
tried to climb on board the ship
to scoop up tea to take back
home with them.
This was not a wise thing to do
because they were caught and
their hats and wigs were dumped
in the water with the tea and
they were kicked away,
literally.
The crowd sort of just kicked
them away from the ships on the
wharf.
So Hughes concludes his account
by saying,
"We then quietly retired
to our several places of
residence,
without having any conversation
with each other or taking any
measures to discover who were
our associates,"
right?
Because they're all
disguised."
"Nor do I recollect of our
having had the knowledge of the
name of a single individual
concerned in the affair....
There appeared to be an
understanding that each
individual should volunteer his
services, keep his own secret,
and risk the consequences for
himself.
No disorder took place during
that transaction,
and it was observed at that
time that the stillest night
ensued that Boston had enjoyed
for many months."
So, not wild abandon.
It's a pretty controlled riot.
However, Lord North was
dumbfounded because he really
thought he had given the
colonies what he called a
"relief"
instead of an oppression,
and he assumed that only what
he called,
quote, "New England
fanatics"
would have rebelled against his
measure.
So this event,
this tea event in Boston,
is proof to him that the issue
no longer is one of taxation but
now this appears to him to be
more about whether Britain had
any authority over,
quote, "the haughty
American republicans at
all."
And this is an actual
transcription of part of the
parliamentary debate over what
to do after this was discovered.
North said,
"The Americans have tarred
and feathered your subjects,
plundered your merchants,
burnt your ships,
denied all obedience to your
laws and authority;
yet so clement and so long
forbearing has our conduct been,
that is--it is incumbent on us
now to take a different course.
Whatever may be the
consequence, we must risk
something.
If we do not all is over."
And another Member of
Parliament said he thought,
quote, "The town of Boston
ought to be knocked about their
ears and destroyed."
[laughter] Okay.
"I am of opinion you will
never meet with that proper
obedience to the laws of this
country until you have destroyed
that nest of locusts."
Okay.
Boston is not popular in
Parliament.
Another member said--we're
moving back in to arrogant
British quotation territory--
Lord North could not do "a
better thing than to put an end
to their town meetings.
I would not have a man of a
mercantile cast every day
collecting him--themselves
together, and debating about
political matters.
I would have them follow their
occupations as merchants,
and not consider themselves as
ministers of that country....
You have, Sir,
no government,
no governor,
the whole are the proceedings
of a tumultuous and riotous
rabble,
who ought, if they had the
least prudence,
to follow their mercantile
employment,
and not trouble themselves with
politics and government,
which they do not
understand."
[laughs]
Okay.
Go back to your regular jobs,
guys.
Don't mess in government.
What are they doing?
Why are they doing this?
They're merchants.
They're not politicians,
and look what they're doing.
They're messing up the imperial
system.
Okay.
The result of that kind of
sentiment would be the passage
of four acts that Americans
termed the Intolerable Acts,
passed in Parliament in the
spring of 1774.
And I'm so on the cusp of
running out of time.
I think what I will do is pause
there since we're just about out
of time for class.
We will continue.
We will add the details of the
Intolerable Acts and then move
in to the logic of resistance,
which is going to look at how
this is adding up to an ongoing
logic in the colonial mindset.
I'll stop there.